poof Saul Goodman is there my agent
called me said they're gonna offer you
at all it's a great show and you should
say yes to doing it and I called a
friend not many people had seen Breaking
Bad at that point it was towards the end
of season two shooting the first season
was cut short by a writer's strike and I
think the show was pretty much
overshadowed by Mad Men to a great great
extent and it hadn't streamed so very
few people knew Breaking Bad until about
the fourth season so I did actually call
a friend I'd been working with and I
said do you know this show Breaking Bad
and he said best show on TV you've got
to say yes to that so I said sure I'll
do it you know it's I I knew it was a
lawyer who's kind of a con man and that
just sounded fun and he and totally
within my wheelhouse
cuz I played Stevie Grant on Larry
Sanders and it just sounded fun and I
said sure I'll do it and then they sent
me the script and had a lot of lines you
know had all these long runs you know of
dialogue and I figured they'd cut those
way back because in comedy you don't
tend to monologue like that and then
Vince got on the phone with me
and because I had read the script I said
I have an idea for this guy's hair I
think he should have a comb-over and a
mullet and back and Vince said which was
really cool of him and I mean I was
scheduled to do three or four episodes
they did say they needed me for four and
I couldn't do the fourth episode because
I was already signed up to do How I Met
Your Mother and so they invented the
character of Mike Ehrmantraut played by
Jonathan banks to carry that plot work
that they needed done in that fourth
episode towards the end of season two I
think the last episode
but hey they created Mike because of How
I Met Your Mother so if you like Mike
thank how I Met Your Mother
better call Saul the first scene I did
on Breaking Bad with Bryan Cranston is a
big scene where I tell him monologue
about the character and tell Walter
White who I am and kind of tell him he
doesn't need me and aren't you just kill
your friend who's in jail somebody in
the in the crew jokes can I get a job on
the sequel after we shot that scene
right there on the set somebody shouted
out can I get a job on the sequel and
everyone laughed because I guess the
character really popped everyone saw the
character is a big big show and it was a
joke and then a few weeks later
Vince was in the I don't know if it was
a few weeks later I think it was a year
later when Saul was coming back and
people would joke do you think he should
have a sequel I think I'd like to watch
that you know VIN said to me do you
think there's a show in this character
cuz I think there is he said and I said
I don't know you know if you think there
is I guess I got to be honest I did not
think so not at the time cuz he's just
as con man who cares I think in in the
world of Breaking Bad I was very aware
that Saul was more fun to watch because
the stakes were low for Saul for most of
the run of the series nobody's trying to
kill him everyone else is gonna die
everyone is at some point losing their
family or they're gonna die not Saul so
it's big it's a big game for him so he's
fun to watch and he can make wisecracks
and he has a lighter energy and so
people are like oh I like Saul and he's
funny and yeah he's funny in relation to
these horrible people who are in hell
but alone is he fun to watch no I don't
think he's really worth watching alone
and when they talked Vince and Peter
talked about creating a series's I said
you got to make him likable I don't
think he's a likable guy he's likable in
relation
the world around him in Breaking Bad
he's fun to watch but they went ahead
and did that they invented who he was
who he really was who James McGill was
and James McGill is likable Saul is a
front and a facade and I don't know if
you can say you like that version of a
person but the real guy that we've
gotten to know in better call Saul is is
a likable guy who you can empathize with
and and champion how do I get him to
call Jimmy McGill I don't I stay Saul
Goodman they call the guy they already
know well it's a vastly different
performance in better call Saul than in
Breaking Bad it's it's way a hundred
million times different the good thing
we had going for us was in Breaking Bad
he told Walter White and he told the
audience this isn't who I really am
but then he never showed who he really
was you never saw him go home you don't
know what his personal life was and
there were a few times in the course of
the Breaking Bad story where he showed a
deeper dimension one time when he's in
the car with Jesse and a few other of
Jesse's friends and he's dropped off
some gifts for a Brock and then he goes
and tells Jesse you should go and talk
to them and he kind of insists that you
should now that's not Saul talking
that's James McGill because there is
nothing in there for Saul
there's only danger in it for Saul to
encourage him to go talk to these people
and so that's a moment where you see
this other character peek through and
then at some point he also tells Walter
White to quit while he's ahead which is
also not solved because Saul doesn't
care if Walter White gets killed he just
wants to make money so when he tells
Walter White you know some people would
say pursue years
position maybe should just back off and
go back to life and that's not Saul
talking so there were these moments in
the run of Breaking Bad where you saw
Jimmy McGill I'm what you're not a real
lawyer it's between you know Chuck and
Kemp those are two really deep and we're
very well fleshed out relationships in
better call Saul Chuck is probably the
most interesting and idiosyncratic
because you just don't see that often
played out in a long form as a sibling
relationship that is that deep and
that's guard and intense those guys are
way too close and they should leave each
other alone but they they both need
something from the other one and and
they're not going to get it then Chuck
kills himself as a way to kind of uh
when Jimmy that's you you look at me and
you see slippin Jimmy I never said that
yeah but you thought it you know Kim and
Jimmy that is an amazing relationship
that more than anything in the show I
think shows some maturation from the
character of Jimmy and shows the
character growing up in and I like that
a lot you know I'm playing a character
who's much younger than myself and one
of the hardest things to play I can't do
much about my face and all that the
makeup people work on it and do their
best and the audience has been
incredibly kind to you know kind of
suspend disbelief and let me play this
guy but one of the hardest things is to
play his level of immaturity
in his outlook on life and towards other
people as a person I read his part or I
have at times and gone
well you just [ __ ] grow up you know
but it's the story of a guy struggling
to grow up and as the times gone by and
he has changed and arced now we get into
places that I can relate to more and
that I can feel personally I can feel
more sympathy for and it's really great
I really like it if this is how you're
really feeling it is I say sure great
five minutes max and in the relationship
with Kim you know this last season
season four there's these moments where
Jimmy is honest with Kim and he just
tells her the truth he doesn't try to
hide it or con her or just escape
without being mature about it and and he
tells her the truth and she listens and
those things are those are those are the
great sides of two characters growing
and of a couple that should work I mean
they should be able to make it work
which is of course going to be tragic if
they can't which I assume they can't I
mean I assume something big goes wrong
and of course I don't want to give it
away any spoilers but I'm seriously
talking as a fan that I don't think that
Saul Goodman and Breaking Bad is going
home
it's a Kim Wexler I dread what could
happen to her but if something really
tragic happens then I don't see how he
could go on so I don't know I don't know
what happens and I almost think it would
be more tragic and I'm just spitballing
here as a fan if she and he were
separated but still carrying on in
Albuquerque and he you know she had to
drive by his billboard he had to drive
by her law office
I think it's easier to maintain now than
it was and the reason is because in the
character's story he's decided to very
consciously compartmentalize his worst
instincts and call them saul goodman and
be that and and when he's that he's that
and when he's home he's Jimmy McGill and
he's a person that Kim Wexler can trust
and love and so because he's now made
this a choice like I'm not gonna just
kind of go through life and struggle
with all these urges I'm gonna put all
my batter just right here I'm gonna
dress for it and I'm gonna be that guy
and don't expect anything good from him
and then when I go home I'll take off my
tie and my lime green socks and I will
be a good this good guy who you know can
is capable of honest interaction and
caring and so in a way it's gotten
easier now because it's easier for Jimmy
I mean I think the character feels
lighter and more energetic because he
goes I figured it out I figured it out
I know what I have to do I have to play
this part so I I find season five to be
more upbeat energetic and kind of he's
clearer in what he's doing and I think
he's grown and emotionally now the
question is can a person make that work
in the real world or can a person do
that that that's what they're asking you
know can you separate yourself out like
that and live a bifurcated existence
like that and we'll we'll see what the
show says
[Music]
you